[blues piano]
DINAH WASHINGTON (Singing):
What a difference a day made.
24 little hours Brought
the sun and the flowers
where there used to be rain!
My yesterday was blue, dear.
C.L. FRANKLIN: Come on down
here and join the party.
Come on.
DINAH WASHINGTON (Singing):
Today I'm a part of you, dear.
C.L. FRANKLIN: Ha, ha!
That's my girl.
DINAH WASHINGTON
(Singing): My lonely nights
are through, dear.
Since you said, you were mine.
Lord, what a
difference a day makes.
There's a rainbow before me.
The skies above can't be stormy.
TED WHITE: And which one of
C.L.'s daughters is this?
ARETHA FRANKLIN:
I'm Aretha Louise.
TED WHITE: Well, nice
to meet you, Aretha.
I'm Ted White.
DINAH WASHINGTON
(Singing): It's heaven when
you find romance on your menu.
What a difference a day made,
and the difference is you.
[applause, cheering]
DINAH WASHINGTON: Thank you.
I'mma record that one.
TED WHITE: Yeah, you better.
C.L. FRANKLIN: My
daughter, Aretha.
BARBARA SIGGERS
FRANKLIN: Oh, C.L.,
don't make Ree sing if
she doesn't want to.
C.L. FRANKLIN: Ree
listens to the radio.
She can hear any song and
sing it back note for note.
And tonight, we got a bona
fide radio star in our house.
So, so how would you all like
to hear a little sing along?
A little call and response?
Hey?
TED WHITE: What, is it
like a little parlor
trick or something like that?
BARBARA SIGGERS FRANKLIN: No.
Little Ree's good.
DINAH WASHINGTON
(Singing): Did you
say I've got a lot to learn?
ARETHA FRANKLIN
(Singing): Did you
say I've got a lot to learn?
[cheering]
DINAH WASHINGTON
(Singing): Since this
is the perfect spot to learn,
DINAH AND ARETHA TOGETHER:
Teach me tonight.
TED WHITE: Ha ha!
Did you see that?
You got something there.
C.L. FRANKLIN: That's it!
DINAH WASHINGTON: Ree's
gonna be the next great one.
C.L. FRANKLIN: Yes she is.
Yes, she is.